[Musique]
était à l'honneur ce dimanche 28 août de
retour après deux années blanche la
cinquième édition du Salon des Seniors a
débuté sa tournée avec un premier arrêt
au parc du vin décembre à Saint-Leu
organisé à l'initiative de l'Association
pour le développement et le rayonnement
de la Réunion la der en partenariat avec
le département la manifestation
consacrée aux personnes de 50 ans et
plus change de format cette année en
allant au plus proche des Réunionnais
avec quatre journées aux quatre coins de
l'île au programme rencontre avec les
professionnels du Bien vieillir mais
aussi animation marché forain et bien
d'autres ils auront toutes les
institutions qui seront là comme le
Conseil général la sécurité sociale et
les caisses de retraite etc mais on aura
également des entreprises privées qui
vont présenter leurs produits concernant
donc les personnes âgées donc les
personnes peuvent venir quoi transformer
régler les problèmes administratifs
puisque là ce peut se faire et puis il y
a des conférences aussi qu'on peut pas
oublier et également il y aura un petit
marché forain donc ils peuvent
s'approvisionner il y a beaucoup
d'activités alors il y a des danses il y
a du sport adapté pour les seniors en
fait on a un seul lieu et pourront avoir
tout ce qu'ils veulent une manifestation
ouverte à tous les âges et à toutes les
bourses l'entrée devenant gratuite cette
année grâce au soutien renforcé du
département de La Réunion partenaire de
l'événement en tant que mère de
Saint-Leu mais aussi vice-président du
département mais surtout président de
l'Union des CCAS de la réunion je suis
ravi d'accueillir la première étape du
Salon des Seniors puisque
anciennement on faisait ce salon sur
Saint-Denis sur trois jours et on a
décidé donc avec les villes de La
Réunion mais aussi les CCAS et
l'organisateur de faire ça sur quatre
communes afin d'être au plus près des
personnes âgées avec plus d'une centaine
d'experts présents pour répondre à
toutes les questions sur la santé le
bien-être la retraite ou encore les
aides et les droits le Salon des Seniors
devient le rendez-vous incontournable du
Bien vieillir à la réunion après
Saint-Leu il sera de retour le 9 octobre
pour la journée départementale des
personnes âgées au jardin de l'État à
Saint-Denis le 19 novembre au Parc du
Colosse à Saint-André et terminera sa
tournée le 4 décembre prochain au grand
kiosque du tampon
[Musique]